alright guys we're doing a bonus
interview this week my friend and former
colleague David Pakman is joining me
today to talk about many things but most
notably his takedown of reza aslan this
week which was really just fantastic
pac-man welcome to the Reuben report
pleasure to be here all right man well
you have had me on your show a bunch of
times and you know we go back and forth
on email about a lot of topics and we're
talking about all this stuff all the
time
so before we get into the Reza thing for
my audience that doesn't know who you
are can you just tell a little bit about
your history and and how you got into
being a talker for a living yes so back
when I was in college at the University
of Massachusetts and then throughout
when I was in graduate school as well in
the Boston area started a community
radio hour it was once every two weeks
kinda like doing it even though I was
horrible at it so I just kind of kept
going and eventually was able to get on
a couple of additional radio stations
and then at a certain point through some
cameras in my studio started a YouTube
channel and just started offering the
show to anybody who would take it and to
condense the last eight years into one
minute we're now on DirecTV and Dish
Network Nightly were on 200 radio and
television stations and we have a
YouTube channel that has about four
million views every month and it's a
progressive political talk show yeah so
what made you think that your opinions
should be heard by other people it's
something I think about all the time and
when I watch a lot of these people I'm
on TV I'm always like well why do you
think you should be heard
what made you think that no I didn't
think that anybody should care about my
views that's why I was so hesitant to
even do anything in the first place but
I was basically just offered there it
was a brand new radio station which had
an empty calendar and someone came to me
and said you know they're giving shows
to people merely for writing your name
down on a form and I thought that's a
low enough barriers to entry I might as
well try this you know and even my mom
like my Jewish mother who loves
everything I do said my first show was
okay so that like in Jewish mother talk
that's that's not that good you know
that is just terrible geez that is rough
and yet here you are and you were also
part of the Young Turks as I was you
were an affiliated channel with them now
you're doing it on your own and you've
had a great amount of success which I'm
very happy for so before we get into the
the Reza stuff though one other thing so
just give me your bonafide so you are I
was about to say regressive you see what
happens every time I say progressive now
regressive why's that come out you are
not a regressive you are a progressive
through and through right I think I am I
mean if you look at my Twitter feed over
the last 24 hours clearly many people
don't think so but yes I try to look at
an issue when I say okay if I remove
myself from the talking points of today
and sort of analyze broadly where the
progressive credentials or what the
progressive values are here on this
issue I go in the direction that to me
strikes me as progressive not everybody
agrees as you and I know yeah so there
definitely has been this split my
audience knows about it well there has
been a split between what I consider
classic liberals and the progressives or
as I now refer to them the regressives
and I think you and I over the course of
the last year and a half or so we sort
of started seeing this some of this
stuff together and we're talking about
it for quite some time and it's come
from a series of different people and
now we can get to your resume oh but I
should say that when I started this show
one of the rules that I laid out is that
I didn't want to talk about people I
wanted to talk about ideas and I said
yeah there's going to be some instances
where I actually have to talk about
people because sometimes they're going
to interject themselves into the issues
so intimately that we're going to have
to actually talk about them reza aslan
happens to be one of these people and
you did a great 25 minute video where
you research and you thoroughly uh took
point for point some of the things he's
talked about some of his credentials
things like that before we get too deep
let's take a look at the video you did
on Reza
another reason that FGM is
underrepresented in the Middle East is
that researchers and organizations are
often in fear of seeming bigoted
specifically Islamophobic for
hypothesizing or proving that there is a
causal relationship between Islam and at
gM this is why people like Aslan can be
dangerous
not only is Aslan going around and
saying that FGM has nothing to do with
Islam he helps to establish a sort of
environment of political correctness
among liberals and intellectuals which
goes to inhibit global research about
these things in the first place Aslan
says quote all of this is to say that
while it is almost impossible to come up
with some sort of connection that binds
countries that have a female genital
mutilation problem it is clear that
whatever that connection is it's not
religious Aslan is very quick to come to
the defensive in justices in the world
despite how little ground he may have to
do so for the most part it's not a free
and open society for women in those
states well it's not an Iran it's not in
Saudi Arabia it certainly is in
Indonesia and Malaysia it certainly is
in Bangladesh Bangladesh and Malaysia
are quote free and open societies for
women Bangladesh is known for its
Islamic vigilantism against women in
Malaysia Islamic sharia courts
notoriously treat women unfairly not
giving them full parental rights and not
regarding their testimonies to be as
trustworthy as men's Malaysian courts
require women to obey their husbands and
men are entitled to women's inheritance
because it is mandated by Islamic
Scripture and by the way ninety-three
percent of Muslim females in Indonesia
are victims of female genital mutilation
well like you said it's not about reza
aslan as a person right I mean Reza
Aslan I too was very taken with him in
that interview he did with Fox News with
Lauren Greene which went viral now I
don't know a year and a half or so ago
maybe longer
where he was asked why why do you know
anything about this I mean he said I am
a scholar of religion and I thought it
was just fantastic and as a person I
have no problem with the guy whatsoever
over the last however many months it's
been I've started to inquire as to
whether some of the claims he's been
making on different media appearances
are accurate whether they're precise
because my concern is no matter which
religion I'm talking about no matter
what the issue is I really want to make
sure
or that on the issues I'm being accurate
and precise precise and my investigation
my research turned up that that was not
the case I could not rely on what reza
aslan had said yeah okay so I want
everybody and I encourage everybody to
watch the video I tweeted out a couple
times yesterday I'm going to keep doing
it so without giving away the entire
thing can you lay out the basic stuff
that you knocked out in the video well
the sort of theme of the video is let's
take a look at some of the substance and
of the style when it comes to reza aslan
as a supposed expert on the history of
religion and on Islam and just sort of
see whether his claims stand up to
scrutiny and whether we can find
evidence that either corroborates or
disputes what he said one area we looked
at is female genital mutilation another
area we looked at was that of human
shields being used by Hamas in Gaza
those are two areas we looked at we also
looked more generally sort of at reza
aslan presentation of his credentials as
well as some of the ways that he
sometimes criticizes those who disagree
with him right so his credentials pretty
much her made-up right well I wouldn't
say that they're made up although what I
would say is the way in which he
proactively presents himself as an
academic historian of religion a lot of
the specific words he used are to put it
very lightly taking a very general
approach to his expertise and as some
would say are outright deceptive and as
you look at that part of the video I
would encourage the audience not to
focus so much on the importance of any
individual credential or claim but more
generally on the idea that academics
tend to shy away from constantly touting
their degrees as the reason for their
expertise and I think that's the
overarching concern right so not only
does he talk about these degrees and
things that he doesn't quite have
uh-uh but he constantly is talking about
them
he's costly touting his credentials
while at the same time minimizing the
credentials of someone like Sam Harris
sure and you know there were two
responses with regard to credentials
that were predominant on Twitter and on
Facebook etcetera that were critical
with me one was you cite Sam Harris but
Sam Harris also is not an expert in the
history of religions Sam Harris to my
knowledge doesn't claim to be a
historian of religion so I took issue a
little bit with that criticism I also
was critique because I don't have the
credentials that reza aslan has and
that's true my bachelor's degrees in
economics and communication my master's
degree is in entrepreneurship and
economics my background is different but
I don't number one use my background as
evidence for expertise in a particular
subject nor number two was I claiming
that my background was the reason for
this video right so you're not debating
him or even debating his ideas as if
you're an expert in the history of
religion or in religion or in history or
anything like that
you were just fact-checking the basic
claims that he was laying out which
actually that is what you're an expert
in right yeah but my focus is on using
the resources we have available and
pooling the resources of my staff to
fact-check claims made by individuals to
see whether they stand up to any level
of scrutiny okay so I again I would
welcome everyone to check out the video
I not only welcome you it I think you
should check it out and I think it's a
it's a good segue for what has become
this discussion about the regressive
left because as you said you are a
progressive and I almost called you or
aggressive because I'm getting the words
confused these days what do you make of
this thing that has happened to the
progressives and you know we can we can
either name names if you want or we
don't have to it doesn't even matter to
me at this point but that this this
constant thing has come out of the left
where there's just one set of ideas that
they're really afraid to critique
everything else is on the table except
this one set and I think you know which
said I'm talking about yeah and you know
it's actually more sad for me than
anything else because I've had
friendships with real people that
I can't call them my friends anymore not
because I wouldn't like to but because
clearly they don't want anything to do
with me because I've challenged some of
their ideas I wanna I I hear you 100% i
100% have that on my side as well but
we're friends and it's it's more of a
sad thing because I think that there
would be so much more to gain from
exploring areas in which the
progressives are not always right you
know one of the problems that we that
the Republican Party has is that you can
have these drastically different ideas
often very wrong ideas and they're
they're sort of ignored and the the
Republican Party and conservatives have
become very compartmentalize you've got
the religious right the pro-business
conservative the libertarians etc it
would be great if on the Left we could
say hold on a second let's not allow
what happened on the right to happen to
us let's not have this split whether
it's a two-way split or a three-way
split let's actually figure out what
progressive values are and see what fits
that criteria some people are willing to
do that and that if you look at the
like/dislike ratio on the Reza Aslan
video I think that's evidence that a lot
of people are willing to do that but not
everybody is and I think that that's a
deficit for the progressive side right
not only is it deficit for the
progressives but it's it's a liberal
idea to debate ideas right that's a
liberal principle more than it's a
conservative principle so if you really
want to debate ideas and that's what you
should be doing as a progressive but
time and again and I you know as you
just said about losing some friends and
it's happened to me as well I've seen
that these people not only but it's not
just that they don't want to debate
ideas it's when they do debate ideas
they do what Reza does which is lying
about what their opponents say or their
motives you know and he's done plenty of
that with with sam harris but then a
series of these guys and we can talk
about greenwald and the rest of them
that they don't mind twisting words of
their opponents and doing using very
illiberal principles to defend what they
think is liberalism and to be clear you
know there is a gray area here and I'm
one of the first people to criticize
media outlets when they do the false
balance thing and as John Kerry ones
said the idea that any random notion
needs to be given the same amount of
attention as what the fact support
climate change is a perfect example of
this experts suppose it experts one of
the experts believe humans have an
impact on the climate the other experts
suppose an expert thinks that there is
no impact on the climate hey it's 50/50
that's a false balance a problem that we
have in corporate media so we have to
sort of be discerning as nuance
progressives and figuring out where may
we be falling into let's give any crazy
notion more attention than it deserves
to where are we shutting down debate
when we would actually benefit from more
explore exploration right and we know
that you know it's using terms like
racist and bigoted and homophobe and
sexist and all of those things those are
terms meant to shut down debate and take
this moral high ground as opposed to
actually furthering debate and that's
why ironically lately I'm having an
easier time sitting across just today a
little bit before I'm talking to you
i sat across the table from Larry elder
who is a staunch conservative and I had
an easier time talking to him than I
would one of these regresses because
even if we didn't agree on everything
for stuff that's completely fine and
that's the point of discourse but I know
he's not going to smear me after this
he's not going to take clips and edit
them in such a way that'll make it sound
like I said this or that or he's not
gonna you know send it to a press outlet
that might misquote me and yet these are
all the tactics that these guys are
using yeah I mean I've not necessarily
had the same easy time sitting across
from conservatives as you're describing
I'm fat I would love to hear more about
how you're doing that but you know I
think the racism example is a good one
because I both sides are using that term
in ways that I think are not good the
right has taken to saying to anyone that
calls racism they say oh you see race
here you're the racist and that's a
disaster right because again it shuts
down debate in one particular way the
left as we pointed out in the reza aslan
clip sometimes taken doing this when I
say the left I mean these elements
within the left not the predominant
majority of the left to saying oh it's
racist to explore an issue in that way
and I think that that's just as much of
a problem yeah and one of the things
that I find interesting and I mentioned
this in an interview that I did with GAD
sad over on his channel is that if you
take the some of the work that I've done
for example and I think probably this
this will stand for YouTube but correct
me if I'm wrong but if you take the some
of the interviews that I've done the
people that I've talked to be it my
Genoa's or Sam Harris our ayaan Hirsi
Ali or Ali Rizvi or Sarah Haider if you
take the work and the conversations that
we've had these conversations every
single one of them the through line here
is that we want conversation the through
line is that we're trying to show you
that there are differences between
people and ideas that not every Muslim
person believes this just as not every
Christian person believes this and
doctrine there's difference between
doctrine and actions and all that stuff
but if you look at what these
regressives are doing they are just
completing everything so that we can't
have any real honest discussion I agree
with you and I would add the caveat that
as responsible progressives we should
also be aware of how hey I'm just asking
questions can be used to do some really
bad stuff like hey listen I'm just
asking questions is is Dave Rubin a
child molester it's just a question
right I mean I'm just asking questions
we've seen that used we've seen that
used in a way that is really bad now I'm
not accusing you of doing that I don't
think that I'm doing that but we want to
remember that I'm just asking questions
has been misused by many people yeah and
we see it misused not only do I see it
on air but I see it on Twitter and and
all the other places that you can do it
all right so I think we've do many final
thoughts on regressive left before we
move on to a couple other things no I
mean I'm already starting to see a sort
of blowback to the use of the term and I
thought initially when you and I spoke
about it and and some other individuals
in the public used it I thought it was
really a great tool to sort of explain
some of the problems that exist right
now on the left I feel like the blowback
that the term is getting now it's it's
starting to make me want to look for new
phraseology and
know if that's for I don't know if I'm
being bullied into that or if maybe it's
there's a better even more nuanced way
that I can talk about some of these
issues you know it's interesting I've
seen a little bit of the blowback and
first off look you're gonna get blowback
from the people that it's identifying
right they don't like the term of course
or because it's as a negative
connotation so I remove them from this I
have seen people you know people have
tweeted at me or emailed me saying are
we over using the phrase is it too much
of a blanket phrase I would say at this
point look four months ago barely anyone
knew this phrase it hadn't even you know
although Maajid Nawaz came up with it a
couple years ago it hadn't even been
mentioned in the mainstream until about
two months ago when Bill Maher mentioned
it on his show so I think part of the
blowback is we as liberals we don't want
to sort of categorically categorically
blame everybody or blame like a whole
group with the word but sometimes you
need a word like we're getting the
reason this is taking off is because of
the phrase I think no I think that's a
fair point and I think my focus lately
has been to instead of focus on
regressive individuals to try to point
out particular anti progressive ideas
again as you said it to go back to what
you said at the beginning if we can
focus on an idea rather than a person I
think we'll all be better off
yeah and actually that really makes a
good point because your video just to be
clear and you did say this but to really
be clear on this you were attacking the
ideas you don't care about him
personally in any way whatsoever your
talk I have no reason to think that reza
aslan is anything but one of the nicest
people on this planet truly I have no
reason to think otherwise maybe you do I
don't know the guy I have no idea
whatsoever
I'm sure he's to quote Donald Trump a
terrific guy right all right well I
don't know about that much that might be
a bridge too far for me but I but I do
see your point you're attacking
someone's ideas not them personally
although I saw some people somewhat in
the public sphere attack saying that you
were attacking him personally
all right so I know we could talk about
the regressives probably till till the
cows come home but let's move on to some
other stuff we both exist I think
somewhere between
online media and mainstream media and
I'm a firm believer that we have to make
fun of and we have to attack and we have
to ridicule and fact-check mainstream
media because it does not do it well on
its own right and then at the same time
online media which for a while was doing
that really well has now very obviously
to me become the Wild West where
anyone's opinion is taken almost with
the same degree of factual 'no saz
someone that actually researches their
opinion such as yourself
how do you navigate those waters and and
do you see the online media becoming a
danger in a way because i'm starting to
think it's an actual danger now - well I
think anytime the barrier to entry to
any particular medium is lowered right
now anybody with an internet connection
and a webcam can have a YouTube channel
where they do news end quote analysis
you open the door to having individuals
that can present themselves as experts
very easily without actually being that
at the same time I feel like to the
extent that the Internet is a free
market of ideas of - with some
exceptions generally the things that
have some value rise to the top
naturally now the Alex Jones Show hugely
popular it has risen to the top on
YouTube although it out conspiracy
theory after conspiracy theory I would
argue it still has significant merit the
production value the entertainment value
the controversy that it creates it's
just not necessarily the same merit that
some other program may have you know so
yeah I'm more worried about the average
news consumer who has a full-time job
they're raising a family they're not
going out there
discerning what is the deal with each
particular source of media they are more
likely to sort of fall into the trap of
equating who knows what mr. Jim Bob
conspiracy guy with the legitimate news
uh program you and I spend a lot of time
on this stuff so we've developed filters
that that are relatively effective but a
lot of people haven't because they're
they're living their lives day to day
yeah a lot of that also goes to the
conflation between presenting facts and
giving opinion right so we've seen this
a lot you know cable news even if you
look at cable news ten years ago there
was still more direct reporting here's
the story here's what we're going to do
and then about ten years ago maybe a
little bit more than that it started
becoming more and more opinion-based and
now it's gotten to the point where you
really can't tell anymore if someone's
either presenting a story factually or
giving you their opinion and that's by
design right I mean because the best way
to sneak the interests of others into a
report is to blur the lines between
opinion and what is fact and we've seen
this with the climate change industry
we've seen this happen on on any number
of issues we've seen corporate influence
get into what is increasingly difficult
to decide whether it's a news report or
an opinion piece and you know sometimes
I'll get emails from people and say
David I love your show because you're so
much less biased than Fox News and while
it's thrilling anytime somebody likes
what I'm doing
somebody is fundamentally conflating
what purports to be a news reporting
channel at least some hours of the day
and an opinion show and that term bias
doesn't apply in the same way to opinion
shows and to news reporting yeah so how
do you as a guy that I know you research
your stuff I think every time I've
watched you on anything whether I agree
with you or not and you do obviously
give opinion after you've presented some
facts right that's fair to say absent my
I do an opinion show there's no doubt
about I mean right III would say I don't
do any original reporting in to the
extent that I comment on stories
released by other media outlets yeah I
feel like that's something that's lost
on a lot of the people a lot of people
that that just watch the online stuff
they don't realize that all these people
that are just talking and I include
myself in this we're just talking about
other people's reporting and there
really is a difference between a
reporter and a presenter that I think
it's lost on a lot of people too no
question about it and so I owe any
opportunity I get to talk about media
literacy whether it's at college classes
the way I do too young journey
lister whether it's on the program
itself or wherever it is i explain you
need to understand types of programs you
need to really understand what it means
to have bias and and you know a great
really great example of this is when
someone says you're biased on a
particular issue because of your
membership in a particular group perfect
example is i'm biased on the
israeli-palestinian conflict because i
am jewish okay this is such a
fundamentally anti progressive idea
because who would say oh gay people
cannot be trusted on LGBT rights because
they're gay yeah that would be a crazy
suggestion to any reasonable progressive
yet with some issues that's considered a
legitimate critique well it's
interesting because I always try to
apply the same liberal principles to all
of the things that I'm discussing so for
example when you know there were these
horrific attacks in Cologne and Germany
on New Year's Day and I saw a lot of
people oh you did a video about it
actually where where you reference
something that I wrote which was I saw a
lot of people suddenly saying oh the
only reason that everyone's defending
all these women is because actually
they're they're going on their
anti-muslim crusade and that it's not
only the height of absurdity it's so
dishonest if if as I said in the thing
if a thousand Jews had attacked these
women or a thousand a walks had done it
or any other you know anyone literally
anyone I would have been defending the
women I'm only I'm not attacking a group
of people Muslims I'm attacking the
specific people that did this act and
this is another one of these places
where people get very murky when they're
when they're trying to figure out what
they believe yeah and it's just before
we started this interview I was looking
at my Twitter feed and someone who I I
thought was sort of a colleague said
it's despicable that I am framing those
attacks the New Year's Eve attacks
you're referring to as Muslim at
and this is the same person that cheers
when I identify a Christian domestic
terrorist as a Christian domestic
terrorist and I think we have to be
consistent if we believe that religion
is a relevant lens through which people
are taking actions we have to be allowed
to state the religion no matter what it
is
right so when certain people do things
they say that they're doing things in
the name of religion the Paris attackers
released a statement right after saying
we're doing this in the name of religion
I have people on the left saying no no
it's American foreign policy and I'm
going guys here's their statement whose
word am I going to take for this and and
I think it's really important to
piggyback on this just because we
identify that the majority of domestic
terrorism in the United States in 2015
was perpetrated by white Christian men
just because we identify that or we
identify that every report from Cologne
and Stuttgart and Berlin and Kalmar in
Sweden and and Salzburg Austria just
because all of those reports indicate
that the perpetrators were Muslim men of
North African or Middle Eastern descent
that doesn't mean we are saying number
one that everybody falling into that
category is capable of the same thing or
is guilty of the same thing nor are we
even saying that that lens is the only
relevant cause to discuss we're not
saying any of those things by the way I
don't think that I know for a fact in
the piece that I wrote I don't even
think I wrote the word Muslim in there I
just quoted the North African descent
Park right and I don't think you said
that either so it's all I did use the
term I did use the term Muslim I did use
that term but yeah I mean like you said
which I'm and again should be very clear
I'm reporting based on what news reports
say I wasn't there right so I'm doing
I'm doing a report and an analysis based
on news outlets reporting on these
issues right I saw one channel an online
news thing where they were covering this
and they immediately turned it into well
you know the Catholic Church has rape
problems and we have all sort of rape
culture here in America and blah blah
blah and I thought this is the height of
absurdity first off if as liberals as
progressives
whatever you want to call it a month
first off you should be defending the
innocent people the women should be your
number one priority but secondly if it
had been a group of neo-nazis doing this
of course they would be attacking the
neo-nazis not making it about us so this
is this is just one of those places
where I think there's just such a
disconnect in logic on the left and I
wanna I want to get that gap to be
smaller because I still do consider
myself on the left as difficult as it's
becoming sure and I think what the
problem for me is when you say I'm
committed to telling the story in a
particular way because I think this is
accurate right once you commit to that
when people start questioning that
presentation you have committed to it
rightly in your mind so you have to
stand by it and defend it because you
believe that it's the right thing this
reinforces the idea that you have a
particular interest in pushing a
particular narrative when the only
reason you're forced to restate that
narrative is because others are sort of
pushing you on it right so it creates
the circle where now I have it the
option of either ignoring the critiques
or addressing head-on whether my video
about Reza Aslan
is really an Islamophobe ik v do it's
essentially a lose-lose for me yeah well
I saw a guy who I'm not going to mention
because I don't think he's even worth
mentioning but a guy that's on
television sometimes who's a public
person tweet at you something to the
effect of do you hate Reza you could
correct me if I butchered this quote but
it was something like do you hate Reza
because he's Muslim or because he's
Iranian and that literally had nothing
to do with your video and it's a tactic
by the way that this specific person has
used on me as well and then what's
fascinating about that when we think
about the absurdity of these identity
ideas of are you biased because you're
in the in group or the out group
somebody responded what I'd like to know
is whether David is untrustworthy
because he's American or white - which
of course I responded interestingly
enough I'm Argentinian and Hispanic
right so I mean it's the height of and
of course I I'm I'm white Hispanic much
like our buddy George Zimmerman
it the point is what are we really going
to gain by pointing out whether someone
with a voice is within or outside of
whatever arbitrary group you determined
is the relevant one man why do all the
Argentinians I know look so white you
are too you need it you need to just tan
a little bit and get some cred Argentina
is 90% white a lot of people don't know
that that that is a shame for you I
think that is a shame for you all right
so all all of this stuff we talked about
the online media we talked about the
mainstream media you now are your
totally independent right so is there
any level of anything you talk about
that you clear with anyone you just do
your thing right absolutely I mean on a
personal level I will talk to people in
my life and say I'm thinking of touching
this topic that I don't usually touch I
don't know what the repercussions are
going to be help me talk through it and
let me figure that out but with regard
to should I not talk about an issue or
if I talk about it take a particular
point of view because of what the
blowback would be absolutely not and
there's certainly no paymaster as some
would describe influencing what I say
and the reality is sometimes I will
cover an issue in a particular way and
some of my paid subscribers will cancel
and that's sad that's a disappointment
because I would hope anyone who supports
me supports me because of generally what
my program stands for rather than my
view on a particular issue but at the
same time I have to understand that if
I'm going to always do the story the way
I see it people will get angry and I'm
going to lose some financial support as
a result of that right and I'm pretty
sure that if you don't have anyone angry
at you you're actually doing nothing
right your attic literally nothing to
the public debate one way or another if
people are watching my show and having
no reaction whatsoever one way or the
other what's the point of that program
yeah by the way I should note I've said
this before but you know aura that
produces my show not only have they
never given me any instruction on what
to say but the day that we started I sat
down with the the guy that's in charge
operations and he said don't make the
show you think we want you to make make
the show that you want to make so I
think it's worth mentioning
every now and again because everyone
thinks so if you work here you're
controlled by this person or even when
you're independent they might think
you're getting funding from me people
love conspiracies on the internet so I
think it's worth mentioning every now
and again sure and it you know one of
our most important broadcast partners is
free speech TV on DirecTV and Dish
Network and there is a variety of views
on so many issues on that network our
views do not match up with the views of
other shows on every issue and as of as
of today we have never been approached
by anybody at free speech TV saying you
know it would be better if you were in
line with whoever else on that
particular issue and for that I
absolutely commend them yeah all right I
got one more for you which is how do you
decide who you trust because over the
last year and a half that we've become
friends and when we've talked about some
of this stuff I think it's all sort of
been couched around this idea that the
media online offline mainstream off
whatever that it really is failing us at
every level and I find it very difficult
to even when I see articles do I really
trust this if any if I see something you
know every now and again foxnews.com
might come out with an article that
isn't biased but even then I'll think I
can I really tweet this what will that
make people think of me and the same
goes for something that I see on the
left or will see something you know
salon did something that was decent the
other day but I know that there's such
trash in general I didn't want to even
give them a click like it's such a mess
but how do you decide who you actually
trust at this point well with there are
a few media outlets which I don't think
it makes any sense to name where we will
not use that media outlet as a primary
source for a story either for political
reasons of Beor because they've been so
wrong about something etc other than
that I basically say let's look at the
fact presented and then let's see what
other sources we can find that back that
up so I guess my strategy generally is
sort of take an average if this is sort
of the average of all the facts is being
presented by a group of media outlets
that generally I find to be trustworthy
that's what I go with and I put very
little trust in any particular media
outlet on anyone
story yeah all right well listen I know
I think you do great work and you you
care about what you're doing I know that
if you got something wrong that you
would fact check it and you would have
no problem acknowledging that you've
made a mistake so I welcome all of my
viewers to check out your channel just
put David Pakman show up in the youtube
search bar is that where you want most
people to watch you yeah youtube.com
slash the david pakman show is a good
place to start
all right great well we will we will
continue this and let me know when
you're doing that sit down with Reza
because I want to tune in it's an open
invitation like I've said haven't heard
from him yet though all right well as
David said you can check out his YouTube
channel and David I thank you a lot now
now go do some work for god sakes thank
you
you